Trump lawyer Jenna Ellis today pleaded
guilty in the Georgia election case and
a lot of people are uh let's just say
mildly perturbed Jenna Ellis raised
somewhere over
$200,000 to fight these charges and is
receiving criticism for in the end just
accepting a plea deal and then
apologizing to the court saying she
regretted everything she did and One By
One The Dominoes fall this is this is I
I have I have trouble understanding how
any of these people could have taken the
position they've had during 2020 and
then just flip in the way they did but
this is going to uh be somewhat
Troublesome for Donald Trump however
he's also filing to have one of the
January 6 cases dismissed on Double
Jeopardy grounds which is really really
interesting as well so we'll talk about
that plus of course you know there's
like World War III stuff happening Iran
is once again attacking us targets the
US is ramping up its forces in the
Mediterranean